This work, Analogia, is by an Argentine
artist named Victor Grippo who was a very
important artist within the late 60s,
70s, into 80s in Argentina.
Having a work of art that has fresh
produce in the gallery is something that
requires constant vigilance, obviously
when you care for works of art you don't
want mold, pretty much every three weeks
we have to change out the potatoes and
put new potatoes in, unlike a painting
that hangs on the wall and you just make
sure there's no dust and no one runs
into it, this really requires us to
really be on top of its wear and care
and the work analogy was one that was
created during a moment in Argentina's
history that was extremely complicated
politically; people had few freedoms,
censorship, and quite frankly brutality
was actually the norm. What he's doing
is taking that very basic scientific
principle of energy being created by a
potato which is of course the most basic
foodstuff, but what he meant was we are
all connected to each other
I mean, although each potato as people
said looks like it's imprisoned in this
box in fact it's each person in their
own place actually connects to his
neighbor and the wires creating the energy
are part of that; push the button and you
can activate it basically, create the
energy so this idea of community, despite
the oppressive regime, was something he
was actually very hopefully expressing
through science.
We try in this gallery to give a sense of
so much of what was happening in the
world because it was a moment that was
absolutely extraordinary. Grippo
represents both the socio-political as
well as a materialistic example of what
was happening in the 60s in the
art world.